مرحبا قبل رمضان كانت منى زكي تعيش التخوف
وقلق كبيرين بسبب الهجوم المبالغ به على
عملها تحت الوصايه واللي لم يكن قد بدا
عرضه اصلا والسبب البوستر اللي تم نشره
فاستفزت بعض معتبرين ان به اساءه للمراه
المحجبه اللي هجمه منى زكي معظمهم تعاطف
معاها لما المسلسل اشتغل او لما المسلسل
يبقى هي تستحق الحقيقه تستحق اعتذار من
الذين هاجموا منى زكي قبل ان يشاهدوا هذا
المسلسل اللي بيناقش قضايا كتير وبيهم
حياه المراه وخاصه المراه التي تفقد زوجها
او تتطلق او غيره سواء كانت الارمله او
المطلقه ليه لان هذه المشاكل موجوده يوميا
في المحاكم من ايام انطلق عرض العمل واللي
يتكون من 15 حلقه
ويعيش مع عائلته بسبب حقها وحق اولادها
بتضطر خلال الاحداث للانتقال للعيش في
دمياط لحمايه اولادها وتبدا العمل في
الصيد ما بين الرجال هي الحقيقه طرحت هذه
القوانين او طرحت هذه المشكله دراميا وعلى
المسؤولين ان هم يبصوا او يعيدوا النظر
مره اخرى في هذه القوانين اليوم وبعد
قرابه الاسبوع من انطلاق عرض العمل هل
تستحق منى زكي اعتذار من الجمهور اللي
هاجمها قبل حتى ان يشاهد حلقه واحده على
الاقل من العمل مسلسل حلو جدا فكره جديده
عن الدراما المصريه
وتمثيل منى زكي في يعني حلو جدا هو بصراحه
مش قوي
في المكياج والحاجه كده لا ما ينفعش مش دي
الست اللي شقيانه وعايشه في الجو زي ده
يبقى شكلها كده للاسف هو حلو قوي وقبل ما
يبدا يتعرض كان جاي عليه كذا
حاجات مش كويسه وكده عشان فكره الحجاب بس
مش دي المين بتاعه المسلسل بس مين بوينت
مسلسل
قضيه مهمه عامه فكره رائعه واحنا محتاجين
اعمال فنيه بالشكل ده ان هي تناقش مواضيع
مهمه شفت المشهد بتاع الوصايه وان هي مش
من حقها تفك الشهادات لابنائها يعني اعتقد
ان في كثير جدا من القوانين محتاجه كثير
جدا من التعديلات فلازم طبعا الجمهور
يعتذر لها ويحاول بعد كده ما نفضلش نحكم
مجرد بوستر شوف العمل وقائمه فنيا وانت
كجمهور من حقك جدا تحكم بس لازم تتفرج
الاول
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات